foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
welcome
I'm gonna cry at the ending I know it
no this is fine
son of a [ __ ]
ligma balls
man
thank you Trey lick my balls
thank you man appreciate it
welcome everybody
time to finish this thing
it's time
we have two bosses left
gearman
in the moon presence which obviously
we're gonna do that ending come on
come on of course we're gonna do that
ending
kidding me what up Spartan hi chimpanzee
Brian yep we got the three chords I'm
gonna I'm gonna use them I promise
let's go to the mall
today is that what you're talking about
yes we're gonna beat the old man with
the stick
this is true
I'm excited for it
uh I need to get ready I'm just gonna go
right into it man this stream could be a
great tree you know go on good
I don't know
30 minutes long
or this stream could be like yesterday
where I fight one boss for four hours
I have no idea
we're definitely gonna need some vials
that is true I can only level up once
which is hilarious with 60s out sixty
thousand
I will consume the courts
no today will not be a sponsored stream
we are going to push that back we're
gonna push it back
uh into October
so no sponsor today we're just playing
bloodborne
um we could try the Chalice dungeons
we could do that as well that is true
oh you're gonna fight the moon presence
let's go
hunted may you find your worth in the
waking State you need money we'll do it
later we'll do it in October
we wanted to push it back so we're gonna
push it back it'll be fine
it'll be fine
just give me my 20.
can I buy bullets they're a little bit
less expensive I'll buy 10.
15.
chalice dungeons would have to be done
before gearman though and they take like
eight hours [ __ ] that
huh
eight hours
okay maybe we'll do have that be its own
stream
but for today we're gonna we're gonna
play the ending
we have all three
umbilical cords you guys said there's
four but it doesn't matter
are there any other quests that I can go
do right now is there is there anything
that we can think of I did the thing
with the brain
uh the dude
in the cainhurst area we did that
so I don't know
I know we only need three but is there
like something cool that happens when I
get the fourth like is it you know what
I'm saying
they're a beast of Their Own
and you guys are crazy
it's pickle time time to experience
German again it's Pickle Time boys Rick
you've been super chatting like crazy
the last two days I really appreciate
you man thank you very much
the fourth doesn't
happens if I have four it doesn't matter
all right
let's eat these things let's just eat
umbilical cords I love that
I didn't eat it I popped it
I thought there'd be like an eating
animation of some kind
bottoms up people
let's go
did you upgrade Evelyn
no
I don't think so
upgrade Evelyn
yeah I see it gives me insight
see that now
I mean I might as well buy some of these
huh
you know like five each
chilling with that
um
I could have Maria's clothes
sick
oh the pistol no we're not using that
pistol
no no no
no
no
no
all right
you guys ready for this
I kind of like my drip right now I'm
Gonna Keep My drip
I'm Gonna Keep My drip
uh it took me four and a half hours to
be orphan yesterday chimpanzee
gearman awaits
okay
the gate is open
such an epic area to fight in
it reminds me of ishin
Good Hunter you've done well
the night is near its end Thank God now
I will show you Mercy
you will die forget the dream and awake
under the morning sun
you will be freed
from this terrible Hunter's dream
yeah
basically if we submit our life he cuts
our head off we wake up from the dream
and the game is over
or we can say no
and he will get mad
he will not like that
at all
not a little bit
I'm gonna go ahead and say [ __ ] that
you think I want to wake up from this
dream dude I don't I like it here
clearly
I killed a nightmare yesterday
refuse
get out of here with the [ __ ]
dear oh dear what was it
hunt the blood or the horrible dream
this guy's gonna be easy it doesn't
matter he can't even walk
right
he barely walk bro
you guys a joke
it always comes down to the hunters help
her to clean up after these silts and
messes
oh [ __ ] tonight
Gammon joins the hunt
no okay
I totally forget how to fight you it's
been years
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
no yes
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I mean I didn't think it'd kill me
[Applause]
that was cool he looked at the Moon
that just instant me you serious
that was so cool I didn't know he looked
like right at the Moon that's so awesome
I just wanted to see what he was doing
wow
well that sucks
good first attempt however
I don't know where to Parry him at all
like he is
very fast
very fast
yes we fought Lawrence
I'm gonna go get some more vials and
stuff
real quick
he gets powered up by the moon presence
dude I can't believe how well they
incorporate music into every single boss
fight in this game it's almost like they
make the boss fight off of the music
you know like it's like they make the
music first and then they go off of that
which is really cool
I still don't know what [ __ ] [ __ ] is
talking about
come [ __ ] and I just don't know what it
is
I know it's a dungeon but
probably not
yeah the song is called gearman the
first Hunter
foreign
yeah let me do this one more time
guys I know it gives me a lot of blood
echoes
for free I understand that I'm not
online we tried doing it it doesn't work
stop it so let me do my little farm
for the love of God
because trust me people have [ __ ]
told me
I promise
up in the morning
it's okay
oh
that worker guy asked me why do I play
games is it because you have no life I
said no it's because I choose to have
many we have many in bloodborne
exactly
we can display the game again and have
another life right
that's how this stuff works huh
thank you again pickle Rick
I really appreciate it thank you
why do we play games
um because I like it and it's fun that's
my answer
I have a good time playing video games
which is why
I play video games
you know
that's all
other than that I don't really have a
reason
where can I get bullets real quick I
always forget
the best place for the bullets
can I run backward from bergenworth
hold on
probably got to be just the woods
and then it's all those shooty guys out
there yeah
why do we eat um I feel like we eat
because we do have to like that is
actually a thing that we have to do do
we have to play video games
no
do I want to yeah
why
because they're fun
I like it
you'll give me bullets
oh only three though I'm gonna go back
here where there's five
yeah once we finish the game I got a
little I thought a lot about this game
sir you're being annoying and stop I
thought a lot about this game
yesterday after I was done
I really did
and
I'll talk about it later
I'm not where I want to be I'm not where
I think I am right now yet again
I don't want to use a bullet
yeah I'm really lost right now damn it
oh well
yeah I I don't know if I'm thinking of
him like or I'm thinking of
yeah I gotta go from hemwick
I think more of what I thought about
yesterday just to like not
[ __ ] you guys from what I was thinking
it like this this game is like
really special
whereas I think Eldon ring is is awesome
for what it is
but this game just it gives me a totally
other
Vibe you know what I mean
it's right from here
it's just a
I think more about this game
you know
then I do Eldon ring which is really
saying something
okay that's a that's a bit far there
mate holy [ __ ] no not Bergen oh
I went to the wrong place again didn't I
yeah I did dude I am so bad at knowing
and memorizing like the areas
adeline's Quest from the research Hall
I think so
Elden Ring's great but I'm not King to
the open world aspect
yeah it might be the open worldness of
it that kind of takes me away from it
too a bit
but I I personally really like
I think it's just here
I I personally really like uh
open world games I do
and and Alden ring is the best open
world game but would I say Elden ring is
the best game ever made
I don't know this because I think to do
that the game has to make you feel a
certain way that Elden ring I would say
has not at least for me
no
no scary ghosts
hey this is where I was thinking
I found it
wee bullets
Assassin's Creed Origins I have no
opinion on that I haven't played it
I stopped playing uh
Assassin's Creeds a while ago
foreign
I don't think it has to do with the game
being linear
on why I enjoy this game more than Elden
ring
I don't think it has to do with it being
linear like that's just a design voice
you know
you know that's fine I knew what I was
signing up for when I played it right
thought I killed you sir
bullets bullets bullets
bullets and we're good
there we go
yes we are definitely playing Dark Souls
3 on stream
I want to finish sakiro first and then
we'll play Dark Souls 3.
personally
I agent Jake no that Skyrim is better
than Eldon ring
hey Skyrim's a great game Trey it's a
great game man it is that's all I'll say
thank you for the five dollars I
appreciate you thank you
I like it the you know I like the combat
of this game more than Elden ring I like
the lore of this game more than Elden
ring I like the music of this game more
than Eldon ring
and I think that's just personal
preference right
because Elder Ring's got all kinds of
good [ __ ] in it
but I think I'd rather play this
hitting Health centering right now crazy
I hope they remastered it too
to be fair we don't understand the lore
of Eldon ring maybe that's where a bit
of my frustration comes in
a bit
uh I I am still under the personal
assumption
that they made Eldon ring purposefully
entirely too confusing
who just have us
talk about anything and everything about
it to come up with [ __ ] and I I'm like
personally I'm just over it
you know where it's it's just becoming
like too much
like the world they put us in is amazing
like it's beautiful it's great but and
then I'm like trying to understand it
I'm like dude this is just
I don't know
it's hard to say
maybe when it's expanded on more with
DLC I'll like it more than I do right
now
but I agree with Angel at the end of the
day it's a personal opinion
I don't want to remaster I want
bloodborne too I like that too man what
like if they can expand on this world
I'd love it I don't know how they would
I I don't know how they would but we'll
see let's try this again
we already did all the DLC
[Music]
hello sir
[Music]
ow
[Music]
stop it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
oh
he'll just go right through that one huh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I can't tell what's happening
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa It's like a wind thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
I like that gun
I always shoot him there for some reason
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I knew I'd get the Perry boys I don't
gotta heal you kidding me
I don't gotta heal
oh [ __ ]
who in their right mind walks toward
that thing
Stan can you ban that guy please
thank you
foreign
why is this okay
foreign
guys
I don't know about that
he's easy clearly
I don't believe no I've done Moon
presence
how about yeah I've done Moon presence
before
so do I have to do gearman again
oh boy
I don't
okay that because that wouldn't make
sense
gearman's dead okay
yo what up Moon presence
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
it brings me down to one HP is there a
way to avoid it
I also can't heal I'm noticing I can't
heal
gotcha gotcha
do I like I just was there any reason
that I couldn't heal
or was that just
the blood attack keeps from healing for
a short time okay
just making sure something wasn't weird
there
gotcha gotcha gotcha
I dropped the video I dropped a short
it should have came out like right when
I started the stream actually
I've done a short every day for like the
last four days
go give it a watch
yeah the music is great in like every
fight
AGT Jake just dropped the video
easy for people to have defeated Gwen
Ludwig great ape on sakiro defeated dark
eater meteor Manus slave Knight Gale and
the Four Kings
you mean this boss
now I must leave the stream to watch the
short
hopefully it randomly comes up when you
guys are just scrolling through the
short speed
that's what I would like
I didn't kill the witch
apparently a lot of people do I asked
the stream the other day Stan and
they're like
uh
that they watch shorts all the time
and I was like really like yeah I had no
idea that it was a thing
so it forces me to Rally
okay
each fight's different for everyone
obviously that's very true like maybe
the moon presence is just hard for me
you know because we beat Garmin in two
tries but it took us four and a half
hours to beat orphan of Paws and I had
like
two comments that were like I don't know
why people struggle on orphanum cause
maybe I'm just good I'm like okay dude
I just said okay in my head
all right let's go back
did I not kill you
die
[Applause]
I mean they're saying
that they're good I didn't say that
we killed Edward T brightness however
you say that in like I'd say three or
four tries
we killed ROM in one try
you know it's just different for people
like the movements and [ __ ] it's hard
you know
is there anything he's weak to
also does the doll say anything
different
now that gearman's dead
girl German's dead Good Hunter okay
goodbye
Bolt
thank you thank you for the boss you I
appreciate you guys very much
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my weapon
foreign
there we go
nightmare slain [ __ ]
230k dude
yeah I might finish the game
again
the doll
are you cold
the [ __ ]
that's me
oh good hunter huh
well at least I'm in her arms
childhood's beginning
[Music]
okay
[Music]
I don't know how that happened
[Music]
easy for project now a sentence
thank you Angel I appreciate it thank
you
foreign
[Music]
that took 30 minutes
no cap
like 30 minutes bro
um
oh we're just going right in it
ah let's begin
oh don't you
don't you okay it took 40 minutes you
may think it all come here bad dream
how fast is new how fast could I run
through new game plus one right now
I don't know what I don't want to do the
Chalice dungeons for some reason
it's really hard
so are they just like actually
much more difficult
all right the doll's role is to be the
mother of the great one
okay well she is now
I don't think I want to do the challenge
dungeons guys like there was a reason I
didn't do them when I first played the
game I think I tried it one time and I
was like nah this ain't it bro
enemies have more Health if you're over
100 it wouldn't be too bad
dungeons paved the way for the tombs and
Elden ring you found yourself a hunter
okay and what what do you think the
weakest part of Elden ring is
the weakest aspect of of Elden ring in
general
to me
it's the dungeons
the the little tombs you go into
[Music]
I think it's the weakest part of the
game
and go straight to the DLC
hmm
at Millennia right millennia
I think they're boring
personally
but then again it's preference right
okay even this wolf
kind of strong
well guys how do we feel about
bloodborne now that we beat it
would it does it make people who have
not played bloodborne want to go play it
[Music]
music is 10 out of 10. couldn't agree
more the music is probably the best I've
ever heard in gaming before
I think it's the best music
hey yeah these guys are [ __ ] strong
and uh okay yeah this is not
this is like a whole other playthrough
huh
that guy hit me with some fire and I
almost died bro
it's just some cocktail
Arcane playthrough
what's the best osc in bloodborne it's
either Garmin or Ludwig
is it Ludwig or Ludwig
foreign
Lawrence's OST was really cool too I did
enjoy that a lot
I think that's number three for me
behind
Lube wig
and gearman
garman's theme is just so
it's just so good
yes gun deer of course of course
[Music]
yeah
for me
for me bloodborne is the best game ever
made for me
it really is this is the best game I
have ever played a hands down even after
all the Elden ring you know uh after all
the Eldon ring
what do you call it
initial hype with it
you know what I'm saying
oh it's in the Dylan it's in the uh
description you can join the Discord
there buddy
thank you for another five dollars thank
you man
[Music]
why do I keep thinking of homecoming
forgotto was last night what's the
digits for your disc good job I've been
at work all day
what's in the description Dylan thank
you man
appreciate you
so what now I don't know I mean
it's the only correct take I'm not sure
if that's there's no correct opinion you
know it's an opinion for me this game
made me feel better playing it than
Eldon ring does
I think the every Everything feels like
it has a purpose
when it comes to the music the
characters the bosses the environment
everything
oh yeah some opinions are garbage but
they are still opinions Everything feels
like it was it was meant to be there it
was carefully crafted
and there's just like so much love
put into this game
it just feels amazing I gotta turn this
down
it's very subjective obviously of course
but that this my opinion with Eldon ring
I love Eldon ring is just so [ __ ]
good it's an amazing absolutely amazing
game that I think deserves to win game
of the year
um depending on how God of War Ragnarok
does I think the only game that could
beat Elden ring her game of the year is
God of War
but God of War is only on the PS
PlayStation correct
is that right
is is God of War only gonna be on
PlayStation
I'm actually not sure about that because
it's on PC now the original one or you
know the 2018 one
what's drg Stan
I would pay to watch you play COD I
played the beta
I played the beta uh all weekend
and yeah
all weekend
it is only on Playstation then it won't
win game of the year
it won't beat Elden ring
if they're what like if it didn't have
any uh if it didn't have Elder I guess
this is competition then it could still
win game of the year but
Elder ring will win just because uh
I mean think about it the only reason
bloodborne didn't win game of the year
in my opinion is that it was only on
Playstation when it came out and it lost
to Witcher 3 that was on all platforms
Witcher 3 is a good game but it doesn't
beat bloodborne
God of War beat Red Dead 2 in 2018
well that's a good point
that's a good point
what what do you think is a better game
red dead or Elden ring
I guess that's subjective that's a very
opinion
just depends on what you like
I think Eldon Ring's a great game I I
think it's better than Red Dead Red Dead
is a fantastic game
fantastic game
[Music]
but Alden ring is just like it just hits
so different
like gameplay wise yeah it's not even
not even close at least for me wake up
wake up
oh I can get another weapon
and try the Hunter X
yeah all these games we're talking about
are really good games and when it comes
down to it
who who decides game of the year like
where where is that held
like the main one does anybody know
I already talked to you
can I even turn in gearman stuff yep
yeah it's Jeff right
80 critics 20 fans
I feel ya
you can't have gearing stuff
[Music]
he decides it with Kojima
[Music]
yeah I don't have or it's this bath
[Music]
wait what's this
Chicago
I got money give me that that looks cool
as [ __ ]
what's the Chicago real quick
use it well what
blood all right
let me come back and I'll level that
[ __ ] up
foreign
it just kind of looked cool there
man AGT what'd you do to me now I want
to play this game for the sixth time hey
is that a bad thing
now sakiro on stream I don't know my
only plan for today was to play uh
bloodborne
so maybe it's just a short stream
that'd be okay
short streams are okay
look
[ __ ]
but that will be
um I want to finish sakiro next
do
we have uh delayed the sponsored stream
till October like later in October
Brandon
foreign
sorry
I need one more level
okay what can I what can I sell real
quick how much do I need
all the cell a lot
less C
I'm not gonna do the Chalice dungeons
guys I'm sorry I'm just not gonna do it
it does not look fun to me at all
from what I've seen welcome what is it
what is it you desire
poggers
level up huggers
shoot
oh that's just a straight up sword
oh
I coded it in blood
and then I wipe it off
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that's pretty cool
that's pretty cool
you could watch and react to lore videos
of bloodborne
hmm
[Music]
that means I'd have to switch over you
know what I think it's just a short
stream guys there's there's nothing
wrong with that this is YouTube
you guys freak out when I do like a
three hour stream you'll be like dude
you're still on
you're still here bro
you're like yeah
but you know it's YouTube short streams
exist
I think next stream we are gonna We Are
Gonna switch to sakiro we'll play sakiro
and then uh
we'll go to Dark Souls 3 after that
okay that makes sense for the sword it's
pretty cool I just like the way it looks
[Music]
you all bosses two hours-ish but it was
a blast all the way until orphan who
took alone 14 hours over three days
would still highly recommend
yeah apparently my four hours to beat
orphan was pretty short in comparison to
some other people
I want to see you beat up my boy gun
deer hey you got it
you have to make bloodborne lore videos
I don't know how I could guys I really
don't
I don't know how I could possibly make
lore videos on this game on stuff that
hasn't already been done
you know what I'm saying
game's been out seven years
with people doing lore on this game like
crazy already
so it's been done I can't add anything
to it
and honestly it's kind of like how Eldon
ring feels dude
even in its early early days here
you know with vati making literally the
cinematic movies that I was thinking of
doing and wanted to do
and Smoketown just going so in depth
with everything in Elder ring it's like
man I I think it's covered dude they got
it they got it
come up with wild theories
I
yeah
like mikola not being in the Cocoon
it's uh
you know
that that I like that video a lot
but people [ __ ] hated it man
it wasn't really it wasn't fun to put
that video out because people instead of
discussing just called me a dumbass
which made me I was like well all right
people don't like disgusting they just
like to have their opinion and then like
scream their opinion
and they get like mad about it which I
find strange
it's kind of like they're gatekeeping
lore potential a little bit
you know did you know the balcony in
bergenworth used to lead to the lecture
theater you visit in the dream so
development and seemingly also in Lori
it used to be on that Lake and got
transported I did not know that
that's sick
that's amazing
[Music]
eldenbeast is that squid thing you beat
after the moon presence there you go
pay no mind to them I mean I have to
it's my job like
I could say I could just ignore comments
but it's the only place I get feedback
on what I do you know what I'm saying
so I I have stopped myself from reading
them because sometimes they ruin my day
so sometimes I have to be like I can't
look at these today
was can't
just to like not ruin my day which kind
of sucks
but that's uh that's how it works
yes I am the Eldon Beast
it's me
imagine
it's me
how great would it be a DLC proved you
right
I am not gonna lie I would be very
I would be so annoying about it
stand you're quicker than me thank you
bro
I don't know what this wolf King is
doing either
up just another one
thank you
wait why'd you unhide it uh-oh
we got it
vindication
yeah
you know it is what it is
it is what it is
[Music]
thank you pickle Rick I appreciate your
support through the entire playthrough
that was my favorite playthrough I've
ever done
I don't think I appreciated this game
for what it was back in the day
no I mean I did I knew how good it was
but
I don't know
it's like the older that I get the more
I like this game
[Music]
need to make some good points that made
me think about the lore some people are
just dicks that's fine
people can be dicks it's like
there's a there's a high level of
what's the word
elitism
elitism and I'm I would say gatekeeping
when it comes to
these games
you know
when did I start I mean I played the
game like five years ago like first time
through and then I speed ran it for
about six months any percent so I didn't
do any of the DLC or anything
and then this was my first like I I
believe we did every boss in the game in
this playthrough
make a meme lore
massive amounts of Elise yeah it's just
it's confusing to me how
um
people think that there's a proper way
to play these games
[Music]
like if you use summons or whatever and
then like some people will freak out and
say like man
this that sucks that you didn't get the
the right experience
with the game when you use like a summon
or something and I'm just like dude
that makes no sense to me
or it's like
you can beat a game however the [ __ ] you
want
there's cheese like if you're using a
summon maybe or an overpowered weapon or
a spell or you know whatever
I would call that cheese
you're cheesing a bit
but it doesn't make your playthrough
illegitimate
it to me like cheese is fun there's
nothing wrong with that
I think there's like a stigma against
cheesing in video games when it's like
it's fun to do that kind of stuff
I like cheese too cheese is good cheese
is good
cheese is very nice
you know
the lore is not solid
we only go off of what we see and what
is told to us those that think they know
don't know the real lord
that's a good point I mean that's what I
try to do Rick literally like with my
out there theories on Elden ring I am I
am personally just tired of people like
calling me an idiot for thinking this
way for not believing everything that
I'm told in the game
now we're all over the place
[Music]
she's as good as not as like multi yeah
exactly
exactly
but I mean go go look at my most recent
Community posts if you want to talk
about gatekeeping
look how many comments are on that [ __ ]
it's insane
of people uh complaining to each other
about uh gatekeeping
[Music]
radon is a rune Bearer on a horse
people get upset when you don't
immediately gain the same appreciation
they have for their favorite boss
yeah I mean okay so the guy I talked
about in the community post right he got
mad because after I beat Ludwig first
try
in our bloodborne playthrough
he he said it was like annoying of me to
say
uh that it was easy
which if you watch when I beat him I go
to you guys wow you guys said that
wasn't easy bro like that wasn't hard at
all come on bro like that's not even
hard for me and then this guy's sounds
off in the comments about like you
didn't have the right experience to use
summons it's not fun to watch uh you
didn't get the full thing like why are
you calling it easy like getting mad
and that just shows a level of
uh social on like just being socially
unaware that I'm [ __ ] kidding
[Music]
like obviously I'm joking with the chat
it's sarcasm
and this guy's like actually mad
that I said it was easy
it was very clear that I was sarcastic
and then he you know he goes on this
like elitist like you got you didn't you
gotta use no summons you gotta you gotta
fight the boss and learn its movements
and all that [ __ ] it's like dude I had
fun
what's wrong with that [ __ ] off
you know you can have your own
experience man I had mine
if you guys watched my first playthrough
of Eldon ring on Twitch I doubt any of
you did because I had I wasn't even
making YouTube videos when I first
started playing Elden ring
um
you guys remember the fire giant glitch
where you can have them run off the side
of the hill and die
I did that
in my first playthrough yes Stan was
there
it was [ __ ] hilarious
it was awesome
it was so it was so funny
I'm sure you were there too Trey
and so many and I put it on Tick Tock
and it got like five million views on
Tick Tock which is nuts and there were
so many comments
of people going
[Music]
so many comments of people going
you didn't properly fight the boss it's
not a legitimate run it's not a
legitimate playthrough
I don't like they were saying I don't
understand how people have fun doing
this kind of stuff
and in the clip I am laughing my ass off
having a great time
so
the world is a strange place man
yeah we beat the game like 30 minutes
ago Madness
exactly so to me that is elitist
that is gate keeping a play through
tally it's basically isn't gatekeeping
guy like tell me if I'm wrong here but
isn't gatekeeping where you try to make
somebody feel like they didn't earn
something or like making them feel
like what they did
what's the word for it
it it's making them feel like they
didn't earn something because of the way
they did it and it was different to how
they did it
which means it was illegitimate
which is exactly what they're doing
I think where they get confused
is that like that is it's like they
think I'm saying that that isn't
cheesing and is legitimate
whereas me having the fire giant fall to
his death
is a thousand percent using a glitch and
cheesing that boss
a hundred percent
nothing wrong with that like we were
saying there's nothing wrong with that I
had a good time it's a totally
legitimate playthrough I it's just how I
did it
[Music]
but
it's cheese
that's okay it's it like I was saying
it's like they hear the word cheese and
they don't they think that nothing can
be legitimate when you do that
right I think gatekeeping and gaming is
you're not a true fan of bloodborne if
you used summons on Ludwig right
how many Millennials does it take to
screw in a light bulb
it's already lit fam
I love it I love it I love it
gatekeeping is adding barriers to entry
yeah but adding entry to what
you know your playthrough your way of
doing it you know it's just so odd
so odd
we're talking about gatekeeping and
souls games mug
we're talking about all kinds of stuff
yeah the fire giant like hey I died to
the fire giant like 35 times in a row
and I was like dude
I'm gonna have him fall off the cliff
[Laughter]
right I use summons on Ludwig in this
playthrough and I had fun
but this guy got mad because I said I
sarcastically said that it was easy
he's like well no no [ __ ] it was easy
bro you use summons you're not even like
learning the movements of the boss and
you're just spamming R1 on them bro like
that's not even easy it's an
illegitimate playthrough like you're
just not having the right experience and
it's boring to [ __ ] watch bro as all
of us are laughing in chat listening to
the music having a good time
and this guy's just stuck on how I
fought the boss
it
I think that's just being socially
unaware of something like socially
I don't know
I think it's a social issue for that guy
favorite area
hmm
I don't I don't dislike any area maybe
except upper Cathedral Ward I didn't
like upper upper cathedral but the rest
of the game I really liked like all of
it
watch vids about funny Elden Ring Rage
crits I'm good thanks
[Music]
yeah we were just listening to music and
having fun like there's nothing wrong
with that
beating the bosses
a real gamer makes friends with them no
a real gamer uh
wears no clothes uses no weapon only
uses his fists
can't roll can't Dodge can only Parry
strafe
and then you're a legitimate player
oh shut up
there is Stan
I've never played dead space before
that could be fun
it is gonna be October soon we could
play a bunch of horror games
an OST tier list that's
sounds scary
I feel like Kane hurts there wasn't a
lot going on there it was it was cool
though
but it was pretty pretty linear for the
most part
just fine
sponsored stream will be later in
October Madness
we uh we delayed it
gatekeeping is only valid when it comes
to PVP and exploits
I I'm not sure because I I don't play I
don't do PVP in these games I just don't
I I think I would agree with that where
if you're if you're using exploits to
beat another player
that sounds
that's that sounds annoying and
shouldn't be a thing
yeah glitching hacking no no shot that's
not okay absolutely not yeah
[Music]
[Music]
depends the only reason I would want to
remake or remaster is so they could
flesh out those two areas
I have a feeling like like what they did
with Demon Souls is they won't they
won't [ __ ] with this game at all
can you imagine the backlash if they
like change anything
if they remake this game
people get mad they get really upset
nah you're good pickle
Eldon ring has systematically ruined the
Soul's formula by indulging casuals and
allowing an easier devolved Hollow
experience without the challenge it's
just a low quality open world game
[Music]
um
just an L take
just an L that's gotta be bait
gotta be an l
yeah it's bait it's bait he's laughing
okay like man bro are you kidding me
come on
like whoa
this thematically
ruined it
okay yeah there it is okay okay like man
people say that though
[Laughter]
no people say that man they do they
actually say that
it's like dog the game's as easier as
hard as you want it to be that's that's
the beauty of all these games I know
you're abating me but I still want to
talk about this I'm just talking now but
the
like especially with Elden ring they
have it's so accessible if you're
struggling the boss you can use summons
you can you can summon in other people
to help that's always been the case in
all these games but you know more
summons you get you get spawned right in
front of the boss so you can try over
and over and over again there's lots of
different weapons that you can use to
kind of cheese the boss and make it
easier for yourself
um
that's great or you can run your ass
into that fight completely naked using
only your fists and like have it be any
challenge you want
so it's all there
so if you were like people do say that
AC I know you're just kidding now but
when people say that I don't understand
it
you can go play however you want just
like with bloodborne just like with dark
souls 3 just like with all the [ __ ]
[Music]
Elder ring is not for casual players I
have no patience dying to the same
person for an hour straight nope I would
say then Trey that you're not using
everything to your advantage
and you are bashing your head against
the wall trying to do it over and over
again like I like to do I like to bash
my head over and over again in a wall
just like I did yesterday with orphan of
costs where you guys are saying like
Jake upgrade your weapon level up do all
this [ __ ] and I said no
I'm gonna do it like this and I did it
eventually
because I I did want to have that
challenge with myself
because I chose to do that
[Music]
you know so out saying eldering is not
for casual players I totally disagree
with that
it's so accessible
[Music]
right I I believe all that information
like you just I'm I'm gonna go ahead and
assume Trey that you're not like uh
you're not looking up
things you're not you know like you just
don't know how to do the things that I'm
talking about right
[Music]
because I I think everyone in chat would
agree if you've beaten Elden ring you
can say that it's the most accessible
from software game right
I would say so
to me
there's just so much you can use to do
anything
and if something's not working then you
have the option to change it up and make
it easier for yourself
whereas like Dark Souls 3 you gotta do
this [ __ ] you have to go and you have to
do a boss or like bloodborne here you
have to do something to to do it
to get through
whereas there's still some things you
can do but you know what I mean
I generally like the game information to
be easily understood
right I I would like this is so
is Elden ring your first from software
game tray
which is Hal in the chat by the way guys
I've known how Kinsey since I was
howled Elementary School long time
[Music]
but is Elden ring your first from
software game
yes then
I think that's where it like because for
me
I expected going into Elden ring because
I played all the other games
to
we were nine okay yeah Elementary School
to I expected to not be told anything
because that's consistent through all
these games
so it didn't bother me that they didn't
tell me [ __ ]
but all the information is there
you gotta look for it but it is there
they don't make it easy they don't make
it easily accessible like you're saying
yeah but it is still accessible
Elder ring was your first two guys you
know
okay
I've known Jake since yesterday kind of
shuts me down
hey that's fine
you like Quest markers you like details
I I get you
I get you I'd say that's just because
you were it you're kind of used to that
with other games like Skyrim or Fallout
stuff like that
uh Assassin's Creed another good example
they have a marker on your map and you
go to the marker on the map
me personally because that's that's a
that's what you prefer whereas I hate
that I [ __ ] hate when games tell me
exactly what to do and I have to stand
at a very specific spot and I have to do
and I have to watch all these cut scenes
to understand like I I don't like it
it's I don't like having my hand held
through through a video game
like think of Red Dead 2 where you have
to stand on very specifics very specific
points to start other points
and it'll tell you exactly where to go
and you go to that spot
you just describe Minecraft
I love Minecraft it's a great game
Dark Souls 3 first game I love it and
was my first ROM server game I met my
man gun deer
wait you've actually have you played all
the way through Dark Souls 3 Stan
miss anything exciting we beat the game
now we're just talking
I don't think there's anything wrong
with that Brian if you gotta look stuff
up to figure stuff out that's fine
recommended weapon twin blades
level that as fast as you can best
weapon in the game
I do like a character just explaining
everything to me telling me clearly what
I'm supposed to do or from this year's
jrpgs being poorly translated it's hard
to follow
I feel you okay
oh hell no I'm way too impatient and bad
for that I got you bro do you think I'm
patient
I'm a very impatient person and I play
all these games
like if you're thinking that me bashing
my head against a wall yesterday against
orphan acos was patience
nah
I was arrogant yesterday
because I'm like I am going to do this
this way
it took a while but I did it
was the last boss you fought we just
beat the game we just beat Garmin and
moon presence
I think that's why I enjoyed this lore
in this game more Stefanos is because it
is intricate detailed and it does make
sense where's Elden ring I think uh I
don't feel like I know anything
I try and then
not so much and then I'll I'll learn
something else in a completely twists
what I think about something else and
it's frustrating
what's the camera boss
this is the camera yes
[Music]
I think Faraz Khan did zero damage in
all the games right
loner boy
[Music]
has the most refined and fleshed out
lore
I think so too but I do think that's
subjective to the person
the person plane the person experiencing
the lore and try and understand it like
kind of like Trey like where he he finds
Elden ring to be a lot
I would I like Trey if you if you can
get as far as you did through Elden ring
if you're still here I very much
encourage you to play Dark Souls 3.
Elden ring is of or Dark Souls 3 is very
much like Elden ring
but more linear and I think you'll enjoy
that
I'm confused about the timelines with
Elden ring it seems like the shattering
happened a long time ago and very
recently
I mean I'm I'm very I'm very confused on
the timeline as well
yeah I would very much encourage
uh Dark Souls 3 for sure
maybe time's broken
[Music]
I mean I've had the theory with Ellen
ring that
everything is mashed together
there's things from a long time ago and
things from very recent all in the same
area
so
like the shattering broke time it broke
space it broke
everything
in some instances like
like gravity all kinds of stuff
but it's so incredibly complicated to
explain that that I would never even
think of making that into a video
[Music]
the overgrown freezing dog
that is
if you say it I'll just man
I need to play through the game again
it's been a while I can't remember the
name off the top of my head
he's extremely easy Stan
if you figured out yeah vort of the
Boreal Valley that's his name vort
Boreal Valley
no game good uh sakiro
I mean I'll say I say Sakira is the
hardest one the hardest from software
game it's the hardest one
I think
very easy to understand lore with it all
because it is a story that you can you
can
very easily understand and get through
uh
best combat is sakiro ah bloodborne's
pretty close to the best combat too
I really likes Kiro
it's definitely the hardest one though
to learn
[Music]
like I I had a friend who who could not
figure out the deflecting with sakiro
and he just couldn't do it but he's
beaten every other game
he just couldn't get through Sakura
because it is quite different
[Music]
Arun is a written code in letters so the
eldering is basically the laws of
physics in that universe so when America
shattered the ring the laws of nature
and reality are shattered it makes sense
does it
I agree with you
I think so too
I think so too but uh
I'm not gonna lie to you
people don't want to hear that [ __ ]
bye
kill it kill it with fire
good job Stan
quick with it
I do I do believe that Elden ring uh
they're like the reason people are
uh confused on the timeline is because
there is not one
there isn't a timeline
the reason like the lands are twisted
and the Topography of everything is is
as weird as it is it's because it's not
supposed to be there
it's a it's like the lands between a
reality all of the realities you know
the Newman Race underground moguin
Palace uh mikola and when he was taken
from the halig tree and how long the
halog tree's been there and laying down
in the capital city and how long more
God has been the king and who was the
king before and when did Godfrey leave
and whoa you know what I'm saying
there's so much to talk about
in the [ __ ] dragons the glomide queen
when did America shatter the Elden ring
when did radagon fix it were they once
two different people but can join
together or is radagon just a
manifestation of her hatred toward of
her you know the land of reeds and
there's
it's a lot
you know
gearman in the moon presence are dead we
killed him in 30 minutes and we've just
been talking for like an hour
oh
I like the music here
uh the problem with the runes is that
those runes represent reality
but when we get them they are insert
boss named roon it gives you HP like
yeah godric
I mean they have to make it do something
obviously
yeah the spirit caller snails the
crystallians
the you know
wasn't there a theory out there that the
rant the land of reeds is bloodborne
didn't I hear that somewhere or is
sakiro either one of those games
best Hub area
I mean I've only played six hours of
Dark Souls 2 but majula is beautiful
it's the only thing I like about the
game
let's talk about real life I had to
spend all my money on a new furnace AC
and water heater hell yeah
that sucks man I'm sorry
why I'm moving into an apartment
also buying a house right now is
ridiculous
I think majula is the best Hub area I
think it's beautiful it's got everything
I need and I'm pretty open but linear
area it takes me everywhere I want to go
just by running through there like Dark
Souls one it's the best thing about Dark
Souls 2 that's for sure
me personally I really like
this Hub area in bloodborne I think it's
pretty very very simple uh
and Dark Souls 3 sub area I like the
fire link Shrine a lot but I think that
has to do with it being my first game
probably more so than like objectively
saying so
bloodborne over Elden ring good opinion
foreign
I hope the DLC for element ring touches
more on either the Badlands mikola or
the land of REITs
so
you guys want my theory
on a thing that I want to make a video
on but I don't want I I'm scared to make
a video on it I'm scared to make a video
on Eldon ring at any point in time now
because of just how people react to
[ __ ] everything I I say
uh is very annoying
okay
so like we've been talking about
I think Elden ring is a Mosh Posh of
different timelines all can join
together
we get kinda we kind of get that when we
go to faramazula and we fight the
dragonlord and it kind of shows us that
time can be adjusted
whereas when we're in the land of the
lands between the topography and all of
the things just randomly scattered in
areas it's kind of like it was plopped
there and isn't meant to be there I
think that's very
I think that's very not apparent but
it's very noticeable like when you
really just look at it it's like holy
[ __ ] this is none of this is supposed to
be here
um so like uh I forget who said it in
chat but all when the Eldon ring was
formed everything was in its right place
everything was in its right uh timeline
in its own
real own reality its own dimension
when it was shattered all of that was
broken everything was kind of pulled and
conjoined and and you know kind of like
radagon in America like kind of torn
apart but also together at the same time
it's just very confusing to understand
but
you know it all just kind of gives me
that vibe that we're all in kind of
different time zones and [ __ ] like that
my theory for the DLC is that we are
going to know 100 percent
that everything is a Mosh Posh
When We Touch nikola's hand
wait you know uh you know if that is
mikola by the way I still don't I don't
know if that's Michel or not but people
get mad when I say that the guy in the
Cocoon is hand sticking out I think
we're gonna walk right up to him we're
gonna touch his hand and we're gonna be
transported into another time and
dimension before the shattering so that
we can truly understand where everything
is
does that make sense
so we'll be pulled back before the
shattering so it's like okay so the
dragons were at this point the Landell
was at this point
uh all of that radon LED at this point
Nicola and Melania were creating the
Haley tree at this timeline it it'll
make a lot more sense when everything's
not so broken and Scattered like it is
right now
right
that's what I think
is cursed forever to be a child but that
arm the Cocoon is huge who like he's a
demigod like maybe him that being that
big is
his child form you know like we can't
say so hard it's impossible
[Music]
that's why exactly is the least played
and wanted people start with the least
for sure
huh from a
wait
are you talking about Dark Souls 2 okay
gotcha
Michela grew that much because of moog's
blood
do you know that for a fact
does it say that anywhere
I don't want to know nothing about the
revenants they can go [ __ ] themselves
that's what I want too pickle I want to
talk to Queen America
I want to talk to mikola
I want to talk to radon because I don't
think they would have a reason to fight
us
whereas when we play the game
everything's broken it's like let's
[ __ ] go everyone is out of their out
of their mind because they're not in
their right they're not where they're
supposed to be
[Music]
you know
was it confirmed Nicholas State Trina
it was confirmed in
uh
removed content
content
I don't know how much we can
go off that because they took it out
like maybe they're like oh that doesn't
make sense
you know and that's why they cut it
or there are a lot of reasons they could
have cut it
why does Moog say he has to leave
Michala alone when he comes in if mikola
was already alone
well I thought it was pretty clear that
Moog was inside of him
as weird as that sounds
he's inside his blood because you know
he drips the blood out
and then he comes out of the blood
you must abide alone a while like he was
just inside
there's your context sorry out of out of
context weird
I think a lot of people miss that
you know like he he drips out of him
and then
you know he's the Lord of blood so
everyone's like huh the Lord of blood he
comes out of blood that makes sense came
out of mikla or whatever that body is
right
I got a text
I got a text
[Music]
from my sister
[Music]
I did see that Megan thank you
talk about my sister bro
I thought you had no [ __ ] where'd you
get that from
I mean you're not wrong but
where'd you get that idea epic gamer
what the hell
is it strange that he drops his arm when
we walk in maybe like maybe Moog moved
him
to drip down so he could come out that's
what I see it as I don't think it's
strange that his arm drops I think that
was just Moog was inside his blood and
then he saw us move the arm down so he
could drip and then he could come out of
the blood
it's probably just a cool entrance
for the Lord of blood right
[Music]
what's the gust of wind that make that
wakes Melania up
do we do we have to think this deep man
like it's probably it probably looks
cool
like that's what from software was
thinking
it looks anime
right
it's it's cool
it it showed the you know
the gust of wind is the Storm King right
how is there wind inside of a tree
I don't know
it's a thousand year old fart
no
no
I mean
the the reason we're doing that Trey is
because we have found in in past games
that from software does think this
deeply about stuff
and that's why they do it like that's
why people go crazy with it like with
all the
really out there stuff because they have
found that they they do think of that
stuff it does have a lower purpose
but I do think when it comes to Eldon
ring a lot of the time that people are
stretching a bit like you know that far
with like where that goes to wind come
from
huh
I don't know
[Music]
Grand sax huh the guy the Fallen dragon
and Landell
that'd be cool
but I I have that theory on Elden ring
is that everything's not supposed to be
there everything's kind of
uh
broken everything's broken when the
Elden ring got broken everything got
broken
fabric of time and space I think that's
why you can see lots of archery trunks
in the uh
the Eldon beast fight I think that
represents all of the other dimensions
and time timelines that exist in there
all surrounding the earth tree
you know whether it was the gray tree or
taken over by the golden order and the
greater will and
[Music]
all these conversations lead to like how
is their reality how how do I exist how
does everything happen in life why is
everything awesome and bad at the same
time
you know
it's funny
so Elden ring takes place in a Land
Before Time not saying that it
the lands between is not in any time
frame it's all of them together
[Music]
why do we need any great rooms to beat
the game you can do it with two or all
of them
I don't know
good question
I feel like this is how philosophy
classes should be you just kind of talk
about [ __ ]
is Free Will real or no
um
great question
is basically a quantum physics no one
actually knows anything about it
multiple timelines intersecting and
overlapping and destroying one another
endlessly that is what I believe to be
true
I don't know if I want to get this deep
with it
it's kind of like real life
like why does everything exist the way
it does
lots of different reasons you know
why things happen why other things don't
happen
I mean
did they think that deeply about the
game probably not
which is why it frustrates me and I'd
rather just have the cool hunt stuff in
a Victorian Place like bloodborne you
got me
[Music]
it's frustrating uh DLC will probably
answer a lot of our questions at least I
hope it will
bloodborne
the DLC will be America going through
radagon's iPhone
[Music]
have a good one Brian thanks man
I'll probably wrap it up here guys I'm
stalling
I'm not installing anything but feels
like it anyway
I like these though I like these streams
where we just talk it's nice
just chatting
DLC will bring us more questions
probably
I don't know all I can say is right now
is that I don't want to make Elden ring
lore videos because I'm frustrated with
it yet again
you know it it just keeps happening to
where it's a point where I'm like I
gotta step away I gotta I gotta back up
from it right
that's where I'm at with it it's just
incredibly frustrating and there are
people who are not frustrated doing
incredible work like vazi video in
Smoketown they're getting the job done
so
[Music]
I don't feel the need to I don't feel
like I can provide any more value to it
you know
oh god I've just been sitting here too
long and the PS5 is going to turn off
there we go I'll just stare at you
I know we beat the game chalk I'm sorry
we beat the game an hour ago
yeah I I think I differ
from other Elden ring from software
content creators
because I actually talked to my
community a lot
you know I I actually stream quite a lot
so that I can talk to you guys about
stuff and
get your take on stuff you know
I don't see a lot of other creators
doing that especially on this platform I
don't see it very much I'd like to see
more of it because I think it's
how you cultivate uh
stronger community
and I find it really fun
so yeah
that's all I got today boys
um what is tomorrow
the weekend Oh [ __ ] okay
I'm gonna be back on Monday I think
I would like to stream every day of the
week
I'm
I would like to make some type of video
on this play through a bloodborne
because I thought it was really good I I
thought this whole playthrough was
awesome so I'll I'll think about
something
but I think I'll be back on Monday
take take the weekend to think of some
stuff and
we'll be back on Monday same time all
right
so y'all have a great weekend
thank you for an incredible week I had
so much fun playing this game this week
we're gonna we're gonna pick up sakiro I
believe on Monday
or uh we started it about a month ago
and we're gonna we're gonna keep going
with it so thank you all very much
peace and love
and I'll see you all soon
bye guys bye bye bye bye